[Music]
sir the police are here please
detective can we talk about this I'm
gonna pay you for your time stop he's
not a cop this is what my son does he
plays these games all that work for one
thousand dollars
if you're gonna steal
a lot
what are you doing here just wanted to
say hi have a good time all right cool
see you around dad
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
he's weak
you like him a little bit
of course they like him he's a
billionaire
we're celebrating what exactly are we
celebrating millions of dollars
roll up your sleeves trust me
you can't cheat on us man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark I really like you I really like
YouTube
you lied to me
we're all human just doing the best we
can you cause your mother anguish and I
will not have it she wants me gone
how do you think it says
not well
[Music]
what did you tell him I'm gonna take a
billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
foreign
[Music]
this is real
[Music]
foreign